global warming will mean more problems
that will mean uh benefits that's why
it's a problem but making it into this
unmitigated disaster is simply you know
is simply silly it's not like a one
degree temperature rise has actually
made us poorer or worse off again what
we've seen is we've dramatically
increased our benefits we're much better
educated we live longer uh we have a
better opportunity in almost all kinds
of ways and we don't die more from
climate disasters we dine 99 less from
climate disasters so what the world
shows us is that despite this
somewhat small problem of climate change
we have dramatically improved our life
quality in all kinds of areas
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissinger
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is an
author and the former director of the
danish environmental assessment
institute bjorn lombok welcome to
trigonometry hey it's great to be here
thank you
it's great to have you here joining us
in our new studio we really appreciate
you coming on the show bjorn before we
get to into talking about the climate
the environment and all of that good
stuff tell us a little bit about who are
you how are you where you are what has
been the journey that leads you uh to be
sitting here talking with two comedians
over the internet
oh just my life story and preferably in
two minutes right yeah exactly so um
i've always been sort of an academic uh
i like numbers i like reading books and
i was like totally thrilled when i
realized that university i could
actually get paid for you know reading
books and being being somewhat smart um
and uh but one of the things i
constantly also said was you gotta you
know sort of pay back uh it's amazing
that society is actually funding you so
i wanted to make sure that they also
hear uh the stuff we figure out uh and
and so you know i wrote a phd on on
stuff you really don't want to know but
i i also you know did like a
three-minute uh uh radio interview on
this in uh you know between two pop
songs and the most popular uh danish
radio uh show to just talk about what
what did i find you know i i think those
kinds of things are important and that's
really how this whole thing started with
the environment so yeah i'm i'm an old
green piece and not out in a in a rubber
boat or anything but i had like the
backpack and the badges and the posters
you know once you've filled all the
trees and caught the last fish
people will realize they can't eat gold
all that stuff
and then i read an interview with an
american economist saying
a lot of what you think about the
environment is wrong actually things are
mostly getting better not worse and we
have no sense of what we're focusing on
and you know my my initial sort of
reaction was ah right wing american
propaganda
but he said something that really
annoyed me he said go check the data and
so i got my students together we figure
out we're going to check the data and
show them wrong
turns out that a lot of what he said was
right not all of it he certainly was
american and right wing
but but the fundamental point was it's a
very different uh message when you
actually study the data and that's
really where uh this whole conversation
on climate comes from i kept believing
that this was just gonna be a tiny
detour of my uh my academic life where i
was just gonna write you know articles
that a hundred people would read uh if i
was lucky uh but this is where i am now
i've sort of you know come to realize my
point in life is simply to say look we
gotta not just listen to what we hear in
the media but actually listen to what
the data tells us and be smart about it
and i'm sure we're going to be talking a
lot about that well very much on that
subject beyond francis and i recently
recorded a conversation between the two
of us in which i said something which
actually i think is representative of
many many other people across the world
which is i genuinely don't know whether
climate change is caused by humans or
not i hear a lot of people saying that
it is who i respect i hear a few people
who i respect saying it's not and people
like us who are not experts who are not
climate scientists the truth is we all
make our minds up about this issue not
based on the data but on what people are
saying right so
what is the truth about climate change
and whether it's being caused by human
beings in your opinion
well so you're asking a social science
guy what's real with the natural science
bit i'm just simply going to tell you
you know i i know a lot of these people
who've been studying climate uh i i i
totally trust them like i trust people
who you know do my gps for me i i mean i
kind of know how it works but i'm really
happy somebody else has figured this out
so fundamentally they tell us global
warming is real it is man-made it is a
problem and and i'm wholesale buying
into that so the un climate panel uh has
you know i i think has produced some of
the best reports where they gather like
thousands of period studies together and
say what do we know and fundamentally
yes because we're burning more fossil
fuels
we put out more co2 and other greenhouse
gas in the atmosphere and all the things
equal that heats up the planet and
remember anything that changes the
temperature from what it is today is
going to be negative both if it went up
or down simply because we have made our
society with
the historical uh uh climate in in mind
so you know uh london if you're based in
atlanta i'm actually sure but you know
let let me just go ahead and say london
uh it's comfortable where it is placed
and athens come comfortable where it is
placed but if you switched uh the
temperatures of those two places of
course both of these cities would be
very uncomfortable so the point here is
it's a question of saying given that we
have adopted to our historical uh
climate there will be a problem as we're
moving away from that historical
equilibrium
and so that being the case
what is actually going on beyond because
i i hear on certain people say you know
we've got 50 good harvest left we've
interviewed the co-founder of extinction
rebellion who is painting a doomsday
scenario
what is actually going on then
so
global warming will be a problem but the
way it's often being communicated is
sort of like the end of the world i
would imagine if you had the extinction
rebellion uh hal hallam right
yes now for for balance i should say we
also had patrick [ __ ] who's a former
yeah
yeah so
there's a lot of of dooms
doomsday i'm not sure whether that's a
word but you know the the the the
feeling of end of times and it's very
easy to sort of uh say you know look at
any one thing that you just saw in the
media and sort of project that out into
uh
uh the next 80 years and say oh my god
we're all going to die the reality is
global warming is going to be a problem
that's absolutely true it's by no means
going to be the end of the world and and
perhaps one good way of seeing that
is if you look at the number of people
that die remember it's very easy to
to sort of count uh catastrophes what
counts as a catastrophe and we typically
much much better at finding catastrophes
when we're close to our age but it's
hard to remember what was catastrophes
in the early part of last century but if
you count the number of dead that's much
much harder to fudge and we have good
data for that for globally on all the
weather-related disasters so that's
droughts storms floods uh and wildfires
and extreme temperatures if you count
all of those people who died
a hundred years ago on average about
half a million people died each year
this year in 2021 we expect that number
to be about
7 000 a little less than 7 000 people so
we have dropped that number of people
dying every year by about 99 this has
virtually nothing to do with climate but
has everything to do with the fact that
we're richer we've lifted billions of
people out of poverty and that means
that people are much more resilient so
the fundamental point here is if we only
look at climate we see a problem that's
right but we also have to remember
people act react they actually do stuff
to make sure that their kids don't die
that their societies don't collapse and
what they do
turns out to matter a lot more and
that's why you know without climate
change it's possible that we would only
have seen six thousand people die
instead of seven thousand people and i'm
making up that number because honestly
we have no idea but it
it could have been much less than that
so in reality we've seen a slight
decrease in the uh it's gotten slightly
less good than it otherwise could have
been but it's still an amazing
achievement for humanity that we've
pretty much eradicated all climate
deaths because we're resilient and
like i said
that being the case what what what are
the negative impacts because
there have been people who said it's
going to spark a migrant crisis that
you're going to see huge swamps of
people moving across the planet as the
home as the places that they come from
the countries that they come from become
uninhabited whether whether it's through
drought flood etc
well so uh
migration is actually one of the things
that are least obvious how people are
going to react because most migration
has become much much easier that's one
of the main reasons so it's incredibly
cheap to move uh people compared to what
it was 50 years ago that's why you see a
lot more migrants
but the reality of course is that almost
everywhere in the planet when people
tell you it's going to be unlivable uh
that's only in the same way that most of
london and most of england is unlivable
unless you have heating uh so you know
look of course if you don't have heating
and if you don't have cooling a lot of
places are very very uncomfortable
actually a lot more places are
uncomfortable without heating because
we're tropical species we originate in
africa
but the reality is as people get lifted
out of poverty and we now down to less
than 10 percent of the population of the
global population being extremely poor
used to be 200 years ago almost 100
percent so 96 94
so we've dramatically reduced poverty
we're likely to continue to do that and
that's why most people are actually not
going to move
because they will be much richer where
they are being part of the global
economy so what is going to happen with
global warming is that your
heating costs are going to go down your
cooling costs are going to go up
probably from most places actually not
quite as much
and what you will see is it will uh just
it will reduce your yield increases in
food so you we will still produce more
food still fewer people will be starving
starving and still fewer people will
problem with malnutrition but slightly
fewer more so we'll not be doing it as
fast as we otherwise would have been
doing that's a problem but again it's
nowhere near that catastrophe that you
typically hear that oh my god we won't
be able to feed anyone of course we will
and what we've seen is as temperatures
have risen
we have seen increasing yields we've
seen increasing
uh crops as well both because we have
higher yields and because we grow on
more land and that's because
at an economy that tries to sell food is
actually really good at selling food
both cheaply and effectively to everyone
so again the point here is we somehow
focus very much on saying the knob is
co2 it's one of the things that we
should focus on but if you actually want
to get people for instance out of
malnutrition it's about getting them out
of poverty if you're poor you you starve
if you're not poor you don't starve
bjorn i want to come back a little bit
because you're making some really
interesting points but one of them i
want to explore first of all to start
with is the idea that actually climate
change is bad whatever direction it
happens in because it disturbs the
status quo so if we abstract from that
for a second some people would argue as
you said yourself were a tropical
species surely
the climate getting a bit warmer is
actually a good thing
so so the climate getting warmer is good
for some things but again the the main
thing is it's just simply bad to leave
the equilibrium where we have built most
of our infrastructure too but one way
you can see this uh and i think again
because we have this conversation where
you can only say stuff that climate is
bad we get a very skewed picture of the
world remember as temperatures rise
you're going to see more heat and hence
more heat waves and hence more people
dying from heat that's absolutely true
but as temperatures rise you're also
going to see fewer cold less cold and
fewer cold waves and hence fewer people
dying from cold that matters because
everywhere on the planet many more
people die from cold and heat even in
south africa so the estimates show that
about 500 000 people each year die from
heat and about 4.5 million or you know
nine times more die from cold so when
temperatures rise
over the next at least couple decades we
will likely see and we certainly have
seen the last couple of decades
more people not dying from cold than
extra people dying from heat that's a
net plus now again that doesn't mean we
should just say hey let me have more
global warming because overall the
problems with global warming are bigger
than the
uh the benefits that's why it's a
problem but we're very very badly
informed if we only hear about the
problems and especially of course if we
only hear about the exaggerated part of
the problems so let me follow up on that
then so the if if you're saying that you
know the bigger problems are still major
and also the other thing is people often
talk about the runaway effect that if
you just let it get out of control then
eventually you start to see temperature
increases that are you know that do
cause a lot of damage so
what are these bigger problems that are
that do need to be addressed why should
people who are maybe skeptical be
concerned about climate change why you
know we'll talk about the suggestions
that people are making in order to
remedy the problem uh because they're
very very significant and will have a
significant impact on people's lives but
why should people who are skeptical now
take climate change seriously
well so
i'm i'm navigating what i think is the
correct way to think about climate
change but it's a very very complicated
argument because it's much easier to say
oh my god the end of the world we've got
to do everything or it's not a problem
at all don't give a damn right and and
i'm sort of trying to
stay on that narrow road where i say
this is a problem but not the end of the
world and that's of course why it's
going to be somewhat costly for us in a
wide range of different ways as i
mentioned it's going to slightly reduce
the yield increases so we'll still see
more food but we'll see slightly less
more food towards the end of the century
that means if we could reduce co2
emissions cheaply
we could do more for food at the same
level of effort from every every every
other parameter that's a good but it's
not you know like the saving of humanity
and likewise in pretty much all other
areas and that's of course why this this
and you're asking me why should people
take this seriously you should take it
seriously because the economic evidence
so you know william nordhaus uh he's a
he's a an economist at yale university
he's the only climate economist to get
the nobel prize he won it in 2018 for
his work on climate and the point that
he tries to make is when you look at all
the evidence on the planet
it turns out that if we do nothing about
climate the impact by the end of the
century will be on the order of three to
four percent
reduction in your income now remember
that's that's a bad remember by then we
will also be much much richer so the uns
estimate will probably be about 450 as
rich in 2100 as we are today so instead
of being 450 percent as rich we will be
say 434 percent as rich that's a problem
because we could have been richer we
could have lifted more people out of
poverty but of course it's not the end
of the world we're still going to be
much better off
our kids and grandkids are going to do
much better on pretty much all accounts
but they will be slightly less well-off
and so it's a problem that we should fix
but what we of course need to be careful
about and that's the conversation that i
try to have right now is we should be
careful not to enact measures that are
so costly
that the policies end up being more
costly than the problem that we're
trying to solve it's a little bit like
having a wrist egg and then cutting off
your arm to avoid the risk take that's a
bad idea we need to find a proportional
measure if you will for climate change
problem not end of oil and then let's
find a cheaper policy that actually
fixes a large part of climate and that's
a that's a very unsexy uh you know you
get you can see why i'm not being you
know as as famous as a
helen uh the the extinction rebellion
guy or even you know people who are just
saying oh it's all crap uh it's a real
problem but it's not the end of the
world bjorn what we've been talking
about is the effect on humanity and i
understand looking it through that lens
because we're all human beings and we're
worried about our own interests but we
haven't talked about the effect this is
going to have on the world on animals on
the ecology on the ecosystems etc etc
could you uh go into that a little bit
for us please
so there's no doubt that it'll have a
negative impact on animals simply
because animals also are adapted to the
current temperature
remember temperatures have fluctuated
wildly over the last uh you know 100
million years so it's not like this is
unprecedented in that context but it
still will be a problem
but again if you care about biodiversity
it turns out that there are many other
ways that are much much more effective
in helping uh uh animals and and and
plants in general in the world that's
about making sure that you set off uh
research where people don't shoot the
animals where they don't chop down
the forests it's about making sure that
we have a clear distinction between
where people can live and where nature
can live one of the ways we achieve that
is by having more effective agriculture
if you produce a lot of food on your
existing land you don't have much
incentive to go out and cut down more
forest in order to grow more land uh
sorry in order to grow more food uh and
and and likewise it's about making sure
that you don't take in invasive species
all these things so even the world
wildlife on many others uh sort of rank
all the things that matter for
biodiversity and typically climate
change comes at the very bottom so again
if you really care about animals and if
you care about plants there are many
other things that would be much much
more effective the second part and
that's another
sort of entry in your conversation on on
the positives of global warming remember
that because co2 is actually a
fertilizer uh it it simply acts to make
plants grow more and one of the ways we
know that is because if you talk to
tomato growers for instance uh they'll
typically uh pump an extra co2 in their
greenhouses because it simply gives more
plump tomatoes
global warming and co2 actually
increases the total amount of green
stuff on the planet over the last 30
years
nasa has found and many other studies
have found that we have increased the
amount of leaf area
almost to the point of three united
states more or three australia's if you
want so the point here is we get much
more biomass we get much more green
stuff from global warming but we may
still think it's you know it's not the
right kind of green stuff there's
there's an argument in saying much of
this is going to be algae and we don't
like algae we'd rather have you know
lobsters or or pumas
but we need to get a sense of saying
this is not all bad and tackling climate
change is by no means the most effective
way of helping biodiversity
hey constantine do you like christmas no
in ussr we canceled christmas and we had
lenin fest instead hosa we celebrated
glorious leader and rewrote story of
jesus to make it better really yes in
our story three wise men were killed and
gifts meant for jesus redistributed to
glorious workers of the soviet union
jesus was put on gulag for having wrong
opinion as we call it in russia happy
ending
right well if you do want to celebrate
the festive season then there's only one
way to do it grab yourself a ticket to
our final live show of the year at the
leicester square theatre on saturday
december the 11th yes it is discussion
with one of our favorite guests aisha
akanbi she is almost as good philosopher
vladimir lenin
yeah exactly our two previous shows sold
out completely and this one will as well
grab your ticket now before it's too
late click on link below during interval
there will be special entertainment i
will ride bear with my shirt off i
didn't realize we were going for that
demographic mate oh yes we are x
looking at the politics of climate
change which is what i found really
fascinating one of our former guests
matt wood matt goodwin was saying that
this is actually going to be the next
frontier part of politics it's a climate
activism green politics what do you
think of these activists who are very
very hard line where you've got um i
can't comment i'm talking about greta
bjorn tell us about better but no it's
not but you know you you've got the
people gluing themselves to roads etc
insulate britain that was the one that i
was looking for what do you think of
these people do you think that they're
hardline but in a way they're necessary
because they're getting us to talk about
it they're putting it to the forefront
or do you think these people simply
hinder the conversation
so
i don't know the people from uh uh
insulate britain i mean i've i've seen
uh some of those videos uh i think
they're probably harming the cause
overall because they're they're very
extreme uh but if you look at someone
more more you know uh sort of mainstream
like greta turnberg uh i i totally get
where she's coming from i mean look if
you
watch most tv today you get the
impression that this is the end of times
you get the impression that oh my god
there are you know the heat dome in the
us then there were floods down in
germany and belgium now there are floods
and in india and floods in china you
know everybody must be dying and of
course what i just we talked about
before no actually there's many fewer
people dying and there's never been as
few people dying as there is today from
climate-related disasters but the media
impression is so strong that you get the
feeling this is the end of times if you
think this is the end of times it's no
wonder it makes good sense to say we
should you know throw everything else to
the side and just focus on climate
policy the problem with that argument of
course is when you actually ask most
people what are your big concerns you
know not surprisingly they're not all
that concerned about global warming they
actually need to get the kids to soccer
or whatever it is you know there are
lots of other things you care about so
you typically get an answer from people
that they're willing to spend you know
in the order of tens of pounds uh per
year in climate maybe even in the low
hundreds of pounds
per per year uh fixing climate
and that means when you start making
laws and climate policies that will cost
thousands or even tens of thousands of
pounds per year per person
you're setting yourself up to get the
elected you you just can't make this
work out as a policy and so my main
concern with insulate britain and and
the many policies that are very extreme
that are simply saying we need to fix
this and we need to fix it fast and
never mind the cost
we're setting ourselves up for a policy
that's not sustainable people are simply
going to vote those politicians out of
office eventually as we saw for instance
with the yellow vests and in in in
france but that's really just a very
very tiny start once we start getting to
the 55 as europe has promised uh the 50
as biden as promised that's going to
cost a fortune we're talking about in
the order a new nature study seems to
estimate that this will cost perhaps a
couple of thousand dollars per person
per year and getting to net zero is
likely going to cost us more than 11 000
again in the us we don't have good data
we also have it for new zealand but we
don't have good data for other places
but in the order you know of more than
ten thousand dollars per person per year
and there's simply no electoral will to
give up that much of your hard-earned
cash in order to do climate policies so
we're barking up the wrong tree we're
trying to do something but the only
thing we'll achieve is getting a lot of
bolts and arrows elected if you want to
be very quick about it wow that's a
really good point and i mean when you
put it into figures like that ten
thousand dollars a year to the average
person
is a huge amount of money particularly
you know if you are correct and this is
all about making sure our great
grandchildren are slightly less worse
off than they would have been even
though they're going to be way better
off than we are
i mean it's not a very i can see why the
extremists are pushing a different line
because that's not a very convincing
argument to really do much about this
problem beyond if i'm honest with you if
you say to me you've got you've got to
give up 10 grand a year to make sure
your great-grandparent
great-grandchildren are going to be
slightly less worse off even though
they're going to be way better off than
you are
why would i do anything
and that's exactly the problem and
dilemma of climate policy so look
climate economics as i mentioned the
only guy who got the nobel prize in
climate economics and everyone else in
the field points out that doing nothing
is a bad idea because the first ton of
co2 you cut is very cheap to cut and it
cuts the worst amount of temperature
rise so it makes sense to cut the first
ton likewise they also point out you
should not be cutting the last ton of
co2 because it'll cut a very undangerous
temperature rise and it'll be
phenomenally expensive to do so what
they try to say is you should do
somewhere in between yeah that's not
totally original to point out but what
they typically show is we should do some
but by no means a lot which is what most
people are saying and that's why i think
a lot of the climate movement has gone
into alarmist mode because they've
figured out if we just say the truth and
we say yeah this is a problem uh so come
on guys let's pay everything uh to fix
this problem that that doesn't play with
most people so you gotta say the world
is ending unless we do something about
this you and your kids are basically
gonna you know it's gonna be lord of the
flies in 20 20 years or something then
of course it makes sense but it's also
untrue
and that's why you need to find a policy
that can fix climate change because it
is a problem but smartly and cheaply and
that's the conversation that we don't
have because everybody's screaming right
now and when you scream you don't do
good policy francis let me ask a quick
political question before you jump in
beyond so i know you're not a politician
or political analyst but let me ask you
this and i know it's an unfair question
why are these politicians then
running off this cliff i would say like
lemmings following each other to to as
you say to their own destruction because
even boris johnson we have a
conservative prime minister in this
country who you would think would be on
the other side of that argument just
stereotypically speaking and yet all of
these people are talking about doubling
our heating bills uh doing you know
getting rid of of uh petrol and diesel
cars all of this stuff that's gonna have
a huge impact on people's lives and it's
gonna as you say result in their
electoral demise why are they all
rushing off this cliff
yeah uh so my my sense and again i'm i'm
not the expert on this but my sense is
for a very long time politicians
basically got to promise you to save the
world but somebody else would pay far
off in the future right and that there's
nothing better for a politician remember
they actually have to
assemble a coalition of a majority uh
and that's typically costly but imagine
if you can say i will save the world for
you not the my opponent i will save the
world and somebody else will pay out in
the future that's an optimal outcome for
most politicians i think that's why
originally they just simply assembled
around this this point it's you know
politicians need catastrophes and crises
in order to be the savior that people
want and climate change certainly
offered one of those
now we're getting to the point where
they've sort of gotten all involved in
this conversation and and sort of
promised and pre-promised a lot of the
stuff it's hard to get out of i also
think a lot of politicians
again just like greta tunberg if you
listen to the media if you listen to
most people talk about climate it really
feels like it's the end of time and and
and you know if if if the nazis are
right around the corner or if you know
if it's a media or hurtling towards
earth we got to just drop everything
else and you know
send bruce willis up and fix it so so
the reality here is if this is the end
of times which i think a lot of people
have now talked everyone into
we're likely to say well then let's get
on with it and let's just you know pay
up all of the costs but of course as you
point out
once your actual heating bill doubles
once your actual bills and everything
start skyrocketing people are just going
to say
no you can't say that on a
family-friendly program no you can't
they're going to say [ __ ] this you're
absolutely right that's exactly what
they'll say thank you so so you know
they'll they'll just simply vote for the
other guy and it's such an obvious uh
point then to say look guys why don't we
just stop all this and you know spend it
on schools and healthcare and all this
other popular stuff and maybe give you
some tax relief depending on you know
what what kind of politician you are
that's just going to be such a a winner
and the real point and this is one of
the things that we forget as well
this has very little to do with the rich
world remember if every rich country in
the world went net zero today
that's yeah the uk the eu the us canada
australia new zealand japan a lot of
other countries if all of these
countries went net zero and stayed that
way for the rest of the century this
would be a catastrophe in so many other
ways but even if we did so it would
reduce temperatures by the end of the
century by less than half a degree
centigrade it would not be nothing but
it certainly would not be the dramatic
impact that you think and the reason is
most of the emissions in the 21st
century will come from all the other
nations that are trying to get out of
poverty so that's china india the rest
of southeast asia and africa and a
little bit of latin america
these are all the countries that are
actually going to be emitting most in
the 21st century and of course it's not
whereas it's unplausible that we'll
manage to get the uk population and the
american population the eu to say sure
i'm gonna you know pay ten thousand
dollars a year to save us
but you're never gonna get the average
indian which makes less than two
thousand dollars a year to say sure i'll
pony up ten thousand dollars they don't
even have ten thousand dollars so what
is basically going to cost them is their
entire opportunity of lifting them
themselves and especially their kids and
grandkids out of poverty they're not
going to do that and that's why we
really have to back up this conversation
we're right now trying to make a policy
that's unlikely to work even the rich
world and even if it did would have a
fairly small impact on climate policy
but will have absolutely no selling
point in the rest of the world instead
what we need to do
is to focus on innovation and let me
just give you this very very simple
picture right now we're trying to get
everybody else to promise to do stuff
that's harmful to themselves so i'm
sorry china could you please you know
turn down the heat could you please
freeze a little more and be a little
poorer and you know eat a little less
meat and all that stuff just like we're
trying to do just like everybody else is
trying to do not surprisingly that
doesn't work if
we could come up with a cheaper
technology a green technology that was
cheaper than fossil fuels everyone would
switch just you know one example uh
fourth generation nuclear which a lot of
people are advocating uh the problem
with third generation which is the one
that we have today is not that it's
unsafe or anything but simply that it's
too expensive but they're saying fourth
generation nuclear could be
fantastically both safe and cheap let's
just assume that for a second if that
was the case we could get base low power
that is 24 7 power
incredibly cheap of course everyone
would switch the point here is instead
of trying to force everyone to do what
they don't want to do let's focus on
innovation because that's the way you
solve global problems simply make the
solution cheaper than the original
problem the fossil fuels everyone will
switch
bjorn
what i wanted to ask you right from the
start is this i've heard this term net
zero get bandied about all the time to
me it sounds like a bar that i used to
visit back in the late 90s you know
let's all go down to net zero equally
depressed yeah
you know equally hopeless but what does
that actually look like what does net
zero mean because i don't think any
politician has actually explained in
detail what that term means yeah well i
mean the the simple technical term is of
course that we will emit no extra
and really uh greenhouse gas uh on on
average uh and and that's simple to say
and it sounds like yeah we could
probably do that but the reality of
course is going to be incredibly hard
remember the uk has actually been one of
the countries that have decarbonized the
most in the world uh and one of the
reasons of course is because you
basically stopped doing manufacturing
and you just become a service industry
uh for a while you were incredibly big
on banking which emits almost no co2 but
makes you a lot of money uh but the
reality of course is you can't actually
outsource all of the manufacturing
everywhere to somewhere else we don't
have another planet that could produce
it so to a very large extent you're just
simply pushing your emissions elsewhere
and
the things that are really hard to do is
for instance
transportation that's what we're seeing
with electric cars sure you can have
electric cars in norway that is
incredibly rich and basically give away
electric cars compared to the cost of of
non-electric cars of course people will
pick them up but unless you dramatically
subsidize them it turns out that most
people actually don't want an electric
car for a variety of reasons i'm sure we
could get into so the real point here is
it's hard to cut most emissions it's
hard to imagine how you're going to stay
warm if you can't use any fossil fuels
and as you've discussed it turns out you
need very expensive heat pumps you can
do it
but it's much harder much more costly
and sometimes less convenient and of
course we totally forget our society is
built on steel and cement which
absolutely requires fossil fuels and we
don't really know how to do this in any
realistic way right now and the last
thing it requires food half the world's
protein
comes from food that's produced with
fertilizer that has been done with uh
fossil fuels so basically we're looking
around and saying i'm sorry is there
like four billion people here who opt to
not live here uh and that's unlikely
we're gonna get four billion volunteers
for that again all of this can in
principle be fixed and you can do this
for a very high cost but it's not going
to be something that's a walk in the
park for most politicians and again as
you say once people start realizing
these costs many of them are just going
to say nope not going to
not going to do that and i'm going to
vote for the other guy who says we don't
have to and that's of course why you're
not going to solve the problem with the
current set of policies
and it's not just that beyond after
corona every country well particularly
the uk is now trillions of dollars more
in debt how are we going to afford this
exactly uh the world has actually become
about 25 more indebted over the last two
years because of corona we've just spent
money we didn't have uh and and the fun
thing of course is that's basically a
bill for our kids and grandkids a lot of
people like to say global warming is
something that we're leaving our kids
and grandkids and that's true it's a
bigger problem for the future but just
boring lots of money to not be
uncomfortable now and just leaving the
bills to your kids and grandkids the
fact that almost everywhere on the
planet we have not fixed uh pensions so
we don't really know how we're going to
make sure that
the people who are working today will
actually be taken care of when they
retire in 20 30 50 uh years from now
but that means we're leaving enormous
bills for our kids and grandkids i would
say that what we should be doing is
having a sensible conversation about how
we're going to make sure that our kids
and grandkids are both better off and
that we make sure we do policies that
are both sustainable that is people will
keep voting for them and actually work
for for uh for climate change and all
these other issues and we're not because
we're simply just
running around scared and a little
headless and just saying no no let's
just fix climate change by making grand
promises that we can't really deliver
and of course that we can't get china
india africa and everybody else to buy
into
i was going to say
that this is my the
question that i particularly wanted to
ask all i've heard time and time again
with the climate crisis
is doom it's gloom it's you know the
world is ending 50 harvest left you know
this is good this place has got the
highest temperature ever ever since ever
recorded
is there some good news or is it all an
unmitigated catastrophe well so
fundamentally you're hearing a tiny bit
of the conversation so yes again global
warming will mean more problems that
will mean uh benefits that's why it's a
problem but making it into this
unmitigated disaster simply you know is
simply silly it's not like a one degree
temperature rise has actually made us
poorer or worse off again what we've
seen is we've dramatically increased our
benefits we're much better educated we
live longer we have a better opportunity
in almost all kinds of ways and we don't
die more from climate disasters we dine
99 less from climate disasters so what
the world shows us is that despite this
somewhat small problem of climate change
we have dramatically improved our life
quality in all kinds of areas and the
real problem with climate policy could
very well be that if we're so over
focused on climate policy it means we
forget all the other things as we just
talked about how do we do pension reform
how do we make sure you know one things
that blow my mind uh almost every kid in
the world is now in school which is a
great
uh
achievement but about half of them in
developing countries still don't learn
anything and so we need to get the
school crisis fixed we need to still get
people out of poverty we need to get
people out of hunger we need to do so
many other things there's one and a half
million people that die every year from
an entirely curable tuberculosis
remember we don't care about it anymore
because we fixed it 100 years ago but
there's still 1.5 million people died
just from that one disease every year we
should do something about all those
catastrophes as well
we are smart species so you know we can
walk and chew gum at the same time we
can actually focus on all of these
issues but when people are just
screaming their lungs off on just one
issue climate it means we end up under
focusing on all the other problems so
look the future's bright
if we fix this smartly the future can be
even brighter but if we screw this up
and if we only focus on climate we'll
likely both make bad climate policies
we'll actually not fix it because people
will end up electing balls in ours and
we'll have neglected all the other
opportunities we'll probably still be
better off simply because the underlying
growth engine uh will still be humming
along but we'll be much
less better off than we otherwise could
have been so that's really my my my
argument here let's not underworry but
certainly let's not over worry as well
because both of those are actually bad
outcomes
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
and bjorn i'm really enjoying this
conversation so much because it speaks
to my pre-existing biases which is i
believe we're in
you know in the ingenuity of humanity
and we've seen that throughout our
history if we focus on solving a problem
we can create technology and solutions
that will work and one of the things i
found really puzzling about the
environmental movement of lay and i say
this as someone whose wife was born and
grew up near in kiev near chernobyl she
had to be evacuated as a kid
and sent to the far east of russia to be
away from all this stuff is the absolute
reluctance to to see that nuclear energy
is a big part of the answer here um can
you talk to us about
renewables nuclear etc what is the
energy package that takes us away from
fossil fuels in the long run and
particularly why are some of them not
being given the appropriate levels of
attention that i think would both agree
that it deserves yeah so so first of all
we don't know what the future energy is
going to look like if we did
both you and i would be incredibly rich
and and we'd also fix the problem in
some way the challenge here is that as
when as long as fossil fuels are the
cheapest base load power
people will keep using remember uh
people love to say solar and wind are
the cheapest ever and they're cheaper
than anything else well that's true
somewhere sometimes but only sometimes
you know the sun is solar power is only
cheaper than fossil fuels when the sun
is shining but most people actually want
power 24 7 which means that unless you
have really really good batteries which
we don't have yet you basically need to
both buy a solar panel and a backup gas
generator and that suddenly makes it a
lot more expensive so they're really
fiddling on these
on these points and that matters because
that's of course why you can't convince
the chinese in the union to just build
lots of solar panels if it really was
cheaper everyone would be building these
so the reality is unless we get
much much better batteries and we're not
talking a little bit better batteries
remember right now the world has enough
batteries to save about one minute of
our electricity consumption and
electricity is still just about a fifth
of all the energy that we use so that's
a terribly tiny bit we need batteries
for months
in order to make this work out i'm not
sure we'll ever get there but possibly
with uh enough ingenuity we can get
there as you mentioned fourth generation
nuclear uh you know the reason why we're
not doing third generation is because
it's phenomenally expensive but maybe
fourth generation nuclear will get us
fusion has always been this science
fiction kind of idea that you could
basically do what the sun does but you
could do it all the time and very very
cheaply maybe it's coming along uh
there's this one great idea by craig
venter the guy who cracked the human
genome back in 2000 he has this idea of
growing algae that is specifically
designed to be grown out on the ocean
surface they would soak up co2 and
sunlight and produce oil and so you
could harvest that out on the ocean
surface and we could basically grow our
own oil field we could keep the entire
fossil fuel infrastructure but without
emitting co2 because we just have
collected that co2 out on the ocean
surface now all of these technologies
are have one thing in common they're
still too expensive that's why they
haven't taken over the world but with
innovation if we spent a lot more
uh resources on innovation in all of
these areas batteries you know solar
wind
nuclear uh fusion
these these algaes and many many other
ideas if we spent a lot more money on
that
we just need one of these technologies
to come through most of them are going
to fall by the wayside and that's the
way technology works but if just one or
a few of them would come through we
would have fixed global warming and
that's why you know i i ran a a a big
conference together with more than 40
climate economists and top climbing
economists in the world and three nobel
laureates where we looked at how can you
spend an extra dollar an extra pound and
do the most good for climate and they
found the long-term solution is
dramatically ramp up investment in green
energy r d just to give you one sense of
proportion here right we we constantly
talk about we need to fix climate and we
have all the technology we just need to
throw lots and lots of money behind it
remember
the other crises that humanity have had
we haven't solved that by telling
everyone i'm sorry could you eat a
little less we've done this through
innovation so if you think back in the
1970s you know we worried a lot about
and correctly so that a lot of people
were starving in this world and there's
not enough food i remember my mom
telling me you know you gotta finish up
your plate because of all the poor
people in africa i never quite got the
connection between my plate and that but
but the point is you don't solve
starvation by eating a little less and
then sending it down to africa the way
we solved it was the green revolution it
was innovation of better yielding seeds
so you could basically plant these seeds
that were just genetically uh made to
grow much much more food so for every
hectare you just simply grew twice or
three times as much food as you'd
otherwise have done that's why india has
gone from being a basket case to being
the world's net biggest net exporter of
rice and likewise for most other places
that's how we solve problems not by
telling people i'm sorry could you eat a
little less but here's an innovation
that'll actually make you richer and
feed your kids and of course everybody
takes that out we need the same solution
for climate we need a solution that says
here's the technology that's cheaper
better
than fossil fuels and don't emit co2
as a naturally greedy man i am fully
behind that statement bjorn uh i'm gonna
ask a question which is is a taboo
question but it's one that everyone
secretly thinks which is
isn't a large part of this problem
simply due to overpopulation
so um there there's no doubt all other
things equal if we were half the number
of people on the planet there would be
less of a problem uh but it's one of
those things that i think are very very
much
a past kind of conversation and also one
of the things that we can do
virtually nothing about remember
when when most people talk about
overpopulation they're sort of like
just right number of me but too many of
you right it's it's always someone else
who's the problem and again it's very
hard to imagine that there's a billion
people out there who volunteer to not be
here uh so the reality is
it is not something that we can easily
solve except for the way that we're
already solving it by getting people out
of poverty that means that you know more
kids are not actually an economic
benefit if you work on really small plot
of land and you don't have any
social security and pension opportunity
when you get old
and also as you get richer kids go from
being a net resource to actually being a
net drain we still love them but you
know they end up costing you lots of
money and so you decide to have fewer of
them and then of course as you uh get
more women uh educated they start having
careers of their their own instead of
just being birth machines what really
happens is what we see is we've we
already back in the late 1960s early
1970s saw the peak increase in human
population and most of what we're seeing
today is simply a question we still have
a very young world where a lot of
young people still haven't had their own
kids but we're way past the problem
really of overpopulation so it's neither
something you can really do anything
about and also remember people are not
just a problem they're also a resource
so you know what the the sort of simple
way to put it is sure they have a mouth
and they're going to gobble up resources
but they also have two arms that can
actually you know help you when you get
old change your diaper
and they also have a mind that can be
one of the guys who actually end up
solving trends in climate change so we
shouldn't just see people as a problem
they're also a resource and an
opportunity and i think overall we're
probably pretty lucky to be in a place
where we have lots of people meaning
lots of opportunity you know when you go
to there's a reason why you live in
london not
i don't know of really really small town
in in in england right because it's much
more fun to be in a place where there
are lots of people so the reality is yes
it used to be a problem it's no longer
and it's not something we can do very
much about anyway
i find this such a reassuring
conversation in many ways it doesn't
mean it's true but it is very reassuring
of course i'm not disputing that it's
true by the way i'm just saying
and of course the important part is this
is you should not buy into it because
it's reassuring you should buy into it
because that's actually what the un
climate panel uh says you know so when
when the latest report came out uh the
uh from the u.n climate panel it's four
thousand pages long uh the un uh
secretary general who loves to go way
over the top said it was code red for
humanity uh and i was asked in on many
tv programs like i'm sorry i have to
actually read the stuff
first i can't do this in like half an
hour uh but after i'd read it of course
nobody then wanted to talk about it
because
uh but but when you've actually read it
it says very much what the other five
reports have said before yes it's a
problem no it's by no means the end of
the world as you think you know for
instance hurricanes
they will probably be slightly stronger
but there'll probably be slightly fewer
hurricanes in the future have you heard
that no you've heard we're gonna have
killer hurricanes everywhere and
remember again
hurricanes being stronger is actually
worse than there being few of them so
there will be a greater impact but
because we're much richer and much more
resilient the damage cost in percent of
our total wealth uh wealth will actually
still be lower but not quite as much
lower as it could otherwise have been
and that's of course nothing you can put
on a sign and go out and glue yourself
to their uh
is that is that why i was going to ask
you because as i you know i was leading
up to it by saying it's a reassuring
conversation and i think a constructive
conversation you're focusing on the
solutions that are actually pragmatic
and practical and that you can get
people behind
and that match up our past experience of
solving problems we solve problems
through innovation through new
technology
why are people like you and voices like
yours being heard a lot less than the
doom mongers and the doom merchants that
we see
glued to our pavements here in london
well i think one reason is it's just
much much less sexy right i mean talking
about the end of the world uh there
there's such a thing as climate porn as
they call it the the the secretly
thrilling end of the world this is why
we like you know seeing these american
movies where they blow up the white
house uh you know it sort of seems you
know it's a terrible thing but it's kind
of secretly thrilling and i think you
know the end of the world has that and
it has that same feel and of course
that's why our history is literate with
people who said we're gonna you know
fail in all kinds of ways and the world
is going to end in all kinds of terrible
ways it's secretly thrilling and of
course you know if it bleeds it leads
it's just much much better for clicks
and views so the the fundamental point
is they have a much much better story to
sell i think the second part is if you
want to get climate policy done and even
i think there's you know quite a number
of reasonable people who say even if
we're going to get some climate policy
done we got to exaggerate the message in
order to get people a little bit along
and i see the the sort of political
argument in that but of course
as as an academic i just think no you
it's not a good outcome where you start
lying a little bit because it's in a
good it's in a good cause because
remember there's all all so all kinds of
other problems that we need to fix you
know we have an education crisis we have
a health crisis we have lots of other
issues in our society and what happens
of course is you know our school
teachers will say sure it's not the end
of the world but we better ramp it up a
little bit so they give us more money to
the schools and and likewise with
healthcare and likewise everywhere else
then we
end up in a society where all of the
people who are going to inform us are
just screaming at us and we have no idea
where we should be spending our money
and we end up giving the money to the
guy who screams louder so have the
cutest pictures and the most crying
babies which is not a good outcome so so
i think the reason why you don't hear
the argument i'm making is because it's
not nearly as media
friendly and also it doesn't serve a
particular purpose it doesn't serve this
one goal of saying
we should do something about climate
because it seems like i'm not really
pulling as hard as i could and it
doesn't serve the people who say let's
not do anything about climate because
i'm still saying it is a problem we
should do some things about so i'm i'm
stuck in that
weird middle which in our polar society
increasingly is abandoned by by by all
the vocal people but of course remember
they're still like the 95 percent of you
know the all the moms that just have
other things to do
and very quickly bjorn do you think that
cop 26 was a success because greta came
out and lambasted it and said it was a
festival of blah blah blah whatever it
or there were actually some things put
in place that are going to help the
situation 5 10 20 years down the line
so it it's a tiny bit better than had it
not been there but it really is not the
right way to solve it and one of the
ways you can know that is it was cop 26.
we tried this 25 times before
and you know i i think one of the the
great under appreciated stories of our
ages the un environment program actually
did a
study of the last 10 years of climate
policy and what they called it was this
this was remember the climate policy a
decade of the 2010s where we did the
paris agreement and everything else and
they called it a decade lost they said
we can't tell the difference between
what actually happened in the 2010s
and a
a a
policy scenario where nobody had cared
about climate change since 2005. and
that should tell you something we have
all these meetings we have all these
promises but the reality is it has very
little or possibly no impact whatsoever
so yeah i'm i'm happy that some people
went there i think they probably did
some smart things especially about
methane but honestly this is not what's
going to solve the problem at best it's
a tiny tiny little bit so in that sense
uh greta
which who might respect quite a bit uh
is right about this fact that we're
mostly talking and not doing anything
about it of course she would like us to
just shut down society because that
seems to be the argument that most
people are making but of course what she
should be saying and what i think is the
right way for it is to say we should be
spending much much more on innovation
that was actually and i don't know
you've probably not heard it either
actually on the sidelines of paris back
in 2015
uh the uk prime minister uh uh what was
his name the guy who lost brexit cameron
cameron right and obama and everybody
else was there uh bill gates i'm happy
to say we had a tiny tiny role in this
they actually went in there and promised
to double spending on research and
development in green energy and of
course nobody did any such thing because
everybody was focused on putting up the
new uh and the next solar panel park
because that looks great on tv whereas
funding eggheads really doesn't but the
reality is if greta started asking and
if everybody started asking for the
thing that really will fix this problem
just like we fixed most problems in the
past more innovation we could do wonders
and oh and we'd also make the world a
better place in all kinds of other ways
imagine if everyone especially in the
poor world had much more access to cheap
green energy that'd be an amazing place
bjorn before we go to our last question
because we could talk for hours but
we're rapidly running out of time and
you're a busy guy uh you you say greta
wants to shut down society yet you have
a lot of respect for her why is that
well i think so
when you talk to teenagers a lot of them
are terrified by climate change and i
think greta has taken that to a logical
conclusion look you're telling us world
is going to end but you're not doing
anything what what the hell and that
makes good sense if you're telling us
the world is going to come to an end you
should be doing everything to avoid this
uh and i think she's calling out the
hypocrisy and much policy of course it's
the argument that the world is coming to
an end that's wrong and hence the
conclusion is not we should do
everything but we should do stuff
smarter so i i think she's she's much
more honest in this conversation than
many others but but you know her
fundamental analysis is still wrong but
i understand why that is the case
because she's simply saying
look this is what i'm being told by
almost everyone the world is ending so
we gotta throw everything at it look
that's the right analysis but based on
the wrong facts if you actually read the
human climate panel problem and then
let's solve that problem
by spending less resources than the
original problem will actually cost
again don't cut off your wrist in order
to sorry cut off your arm in order to
cure wrist egg
bjorn it has been an absolutely
brilliant interview like constantine
said i could happily sit here and talk
to you for hours but it has to come to
an end and the question we always ask at
the end is what's the one thing we're
not talking about but we really should
be
so i would love to talk to you about
lots of things but actually i just want
to briefly mention you know this is not
actually my day job
i run a think tank called the copenhagen
consensus where we look at the world's
big problems and how we can smartly fix
them and and and what we never talk
about are all these other issues we
briefly mentioned in the interview right
the fact that people die from easily
curable infectious diseases that we
don't have good education that we have
terrible health that we have all these
other problems remember about 300 000
women die in childbirth every year and
2.1 million kids die in in their first
month of life and we know how to fix all
of these problems and often very very
cheaply so my day job is actually trying
to point out all these other great
things that we can do
at very low cost that could help
humanity enormously and as you might
have surmised nobody cares a little bit
in the in the in the third world right
but this is not sexy but when you can
you know sort of run to the next
hurricane that just hit the u.s and say
global warming
that it is a problem but some way
somehow we have lost track of what
really matters and what are the
important things you know if you look at
what is the most environmentally
damaging
problem what kills most people not
global warming the world health
organization estimate about 150 000
people die from global warming every
year and i i would dispute that but we
could get into that
no it's the seven million people who die
from indoor and outdoor air pollution
now outdoor air pollution most people
know that's basically a problem of of
low development you need to put
scrubbers in your coal fire power plants
boring but would help a lot of people
indoor air pollution is the fact that
about three billion people every year so
almost half this world's population are
so poor
they cook and keep warm with dirty fuels
like dung cardboard and uh wood that's a
terrible way to heat and cook and what
that means is most of these people so 3
billion people live indoors where it's
about 10 times more polluted than it is
outdoor in beijing we don't hear about
that because it's not sexy so again
the thing we don't talk about are all
these other problems that we could do so
much about at very low cost so you know
for instance we could do something about
maternal and child deaths
one pound would save
so many people that you would do about
87 pounds of social good for every pound
spent that's a phenomenal payback
compared to you know for instance
climate change if we do it really
smartly you can get 11 pounds back on
your pound that's still pretty good but
much of our climate policy you pay a
pound for instance in paris and you get
11 pence back which is a really terrible
outcome so my job and the thing we don't
talk about is how we prioritize the
entire world not just the thing that
gets to the top of the news
bjorn thank you so much for that the
king of all things unsexy we're gonna
ask you a couple of questions for our
local supporters in a second but for now
guys thank you so much for watching
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant interview like this one or raw
show all of them go out 7 p.m uk time
and if you want your trigonometry on the
go it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below